the 42-inch lg c2 is the best tv you can
buy for your desktop right now and
here's why while traditional wisdom
states that bigger is always better
getting the right size of display for
your pc and desk is going to be a
challenge
at 42 inches this tv is probably the
best display you can get if you're
looking for a 16 by 9 4k display
anything curve and you'll want to
consider the alienware aw 3423 dw before
we get into it here agriculture will
cover plenty of topics so while the next
video might differ from this it's
definitely aim to tickle your inner geek
right off the bat let's go over specs
the lg c2 42 inch measures 93 cm by 54cm
which is actually 14cm slimmer and atm
shorter than the previous lg c1 this
means it goes really well with my desk
which has a depth of 80 centimeters
giving me plenty of room by the side as
well without making it too cramped when
it comes to setup do note there needs to
be some level prep needed if you are
looking to plant it on an arm like i
have with the ergotron hx monitor arm
there's a small bump at the back which
requires you to get some spaces in
ensuring that the visa bracket adapter
is able to be mounted on links to all
the items used in this video can be
found in the description below
having a smaller screen also means
there's greater pixel density as well
with 105 ppi this means that text looks
great and it will be an enjoyable
experience overall or it cannot be
compared to dedicated monitors i found
that compared to other displays in this
class like the rog pg for the uq which i
had previously reviewed the lg c2 is the
superior experience in order to manage
the massive display my go to application
is power toys fancy zones which allows
me to manage all the different windows
and ensure that they all snap nicely in
place
the lg c2 can achieve
1499 nits of peak brightness with hdr on
but the irritating part is that the
display has a very aggressive auto
brightness limiter or abl
while we enjoy our oleds nice and bright
lg is playing it safe to help your
screen go in the distance
the abl kicks in about 1 minute and gets
as low as 40 dimmer after 5 minutes
working on a document like this script
is considered an idle task and the abl
will kick in quickly
the abl can get irritating and adds to
eye fatigue a great deal
especially if you have been working on a
monitor for some time
the only way to get rid of abl
permanently would be to go to the
service menu of the tv with a special
remote otherwise you might find yourself
moving your windows time and again to
get the brightness back to your
preferred setting
when you get this tv there's a few
things to actually take note of when
setting it up to make sure it's perfect
for computer use firstly be sure to
visit the home menu and ensure the hdmi
port is set to pc
this way you'll be able to get the full
120hz refresh rate for smooth pc use as
i'll be using this mostly for gaming
i've kept the default settings of the
display
locked to game setting mode most of the
time but i do recommend to play around
with the settings to see what suits your
preferences best it's safe to say that
with lg and their oled tech
there's really little issue with the
quality of their panels pretty much
everything that i've shown at the tv
looks great being a tv the top of the
line features can be found here as well
we have dolby vision and hdr 10 all
ensuring that whether you're on disney
plus or on netflix every piece of
content will look great
this is definitely something i've quite
missed when using a regular computer
monitor an important tip is do yourself
a favor and turn off the home settings
so that you won't be greeted with the
home ui each time you power on the lg z2
when it comes to the panel and viewing
angles between this tv and the c bun
from last year there's no real
discernable difference here which i've
noticed and
that makes it a bit of a shame my guess
is that we're pretty much at the peak of
what oled tvs can offer for this
generation and lg has no incentive to
innovate past the current standard for
one
considering that we have seen excellent
qd oled panels from samsung being
offered in the alienware aw3423dw
will want to stay on their toes and keep
an eye on the competition
outside of that the screen is still
great and lg seems to know their panel
best and has been able to coax the best
performance from the display looking
back at how other oled tvs have fed
simply having an oled display doesn't
always make it great do note that the
screen is rather glossy so if you have
it next to a window there will be some
level of glare however
comparing this to the rog pg-48 uq which
had a matte screen i would definitely
pick a glossy screen having usable for
extended periods of time
connectivity wise lg has bet no quarter
this time around
all ports on the lg c2 are hdmi 2.1
ready
so you'll be able to get the best out of
your devices when you plug in either
your pc ps5 or xbox series x while the
frame rates are kept at only 100 hertz
this might be an issue to the pc master
race family but this time around at
least there's no need for your devices
to compete for ports
with everything plugged in there's even
a span hdmi port available for that
mythical 4k nintendo switch
if it ever happens being pretty much the
only oled tv manufacturer that supports
nvidia's g-sync and freesync
lg has the monopoly when it comes to
supporting users who own different gpus
when it comes to windows hdr i found
that this is the only tv so far that
i've used that had the least amount of
issues when getting it to look right out
of the box
it's much more enjoyable to simply get
into the game and start playing right
away without having to fiddle around
with the settings too much
on the ps5 and the xbox series x side of
things these standards have been kept
here with all m and vrr supported across
the board with the lg c2 we'll be also
getting a brand new gaming manual
users will be able to see the concurrent
refresh rates as well and ensure that
you're getting maximum frames in terms
of picture modes i've kept it to
standard as i feel it's optimal for my
use but feel free to play around with
these settings to ensure that it's
perfect for your own use while the
display does allow for ultra wide modes
in the form of a 32x9 and 21x9
these modes look weird and does come off
a bit pixelated hence my preferred
option is to keep it to windowed mode
for certain games and it allows me to
multitask as well when streaming
after having cycled through android tv
samsung's tizen os
lg's web os is okay by most standards
my preference is towards the v-mode
style remote controller
it's great as it allows you to navigate
around manuals pretty quickly
it's not the worst ui out there but it
does feel slightly slower than last
year's c1 model navigating between menus
doesn't feel that snappy compared to
other brands and it's something lg would
need to take note of as they work
towards their next iteration
order wise this is an area that
potential buyers of the 42-inch lg c2
need to take note off
because of its overall smaller footprint
the tv has 20 watt speakers instead of
40 watt speakers found in its 48 inch c2
models and larger this results in lower
sound volumes overall but it should not
matter if you're using headphones with
this tv
the tricky point in this juncture is
really down to price
across all the prices we have seen the
42-inch lg c2 tv is pretty close in
price point to the 48-inch model while
the size does justify the practical use
the difference in price might not
as much as we like to recommend the
42-inch lg c2 right off the bat it might
be an even more prudent choice to pick
this up when it goes on sale knowing lg
these discounts come pretty hard and
fast
when it comes to practical use the 42
inch lg c2 is definitely right size to
be used as a computer monitor for
everyday use if you are looking for a
16x9 display
if curved gaming monitors are more of
your thing
the alienware is the strong alternative
do check out the rest of the videos on
gaming displays right here
from a hardware standpoint the rog
pg48uq is a solid contender if you are
looking for a oled display alternatives
outside of lg especially for pc use